l'inde a attaqué voici vous avez vu que
nous sommes allés au souk avec kelly et
ya un moment où on avait pris avait
préparé un piège mais le piège est
tellement mal fait jean-michel n'était
pas au courant mais jean michel et moi
ou comprend tout de suite qu'il ya un
piège et on est mort de rire tout le dos
et vous allez voir que kelly elle elle
continue sa diva
[Musique]
on n'a pas du tout même niveau offrir je
dresse pas mais parce qu'il croit que je
vais jouer contre un club professionnel
g5 un joueur de la région
son métier papam et et à des tableaux de
voitures n'ont pas classe en voiture on
voit la photo soit cet après-midi juste
derrière c'est pas un siège connaissent
un petit peu cyril quand même hein donc
le pratiquent tout petit peu des
méthodes du monsieur
non monsieur mais je ne connais pas
d'être là ça va bien ça me dit quoi sur
tout va merci monsieur
jouer bien
[Musique]
c'est rien t'as rien à rien
t'as rien qui évite à rien
[Musique]
sur laquelle on n'a rien kenny ça va ça
va qu'il est drôle et adore et défaire
les faire pour guérir son bien mais s'en
sort bien
[Musique]